well this afternoon we still have very  few details about a shooting up in north  las vegas a police officer shot a man  after a domestic dispute but the  department has offered little else at  this moment this happened near shadow  creek golf course off washburn and losey  bianca holman has what we do know so far  just after 1 30 wednesday morning north  las vegas police responded to a domestic  violence call that took place right here  in this neighborhood near washburn and  losey police received several calls a  man involved was armed and ran away from  the house when officers arrived they  made contact with the suspect during  that incident  the subject was fired upon he did  sustain a gunshot wound and was  transported to umc hospital so as for  that the  person is alive as for the officer he is  uninjured officers say the domestic  violence victim is ok police tell us  they plan to release more information  about the incident within the next 72  hours bianca holman live local now